good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
happy wednesday it is already hump day
we
love short week here at the morning
toast
we love it so much it's a hump day and i
am sitting next to do
and so i just feel so full aroused
would you agree my heart is fall and
aroused
in our house and my heart is aroused
welcome back we have been gone for quite
some time we apologize for that but it
feels good
it also feels like no time has passed it
was just the other day we were sitting
here
sans makeup yes oh my god how crazy were
we
we did a no makeup and we had so much
hope in front of us you know a long
weekend on the horizon
and you know what we have to acknowledge
the space that we're in it is wednesday
already like we only have like
you know two and a half more days of
work you guys what's in the weekend
we've been in worse spaces before so
even though you would think like we're
back from the long weekend
the long weekend gave us you know a
shorter week
for us it was shorter but for most
people was still short
yeah i mean we love a shorty and it's
like june like we just like strolled
right into june right into june right
into pride month happy pride to all of
our lgbtq plus
toasters hope you have an amazing month
and life
i can't believe it's june i know that's
a curveball that is something i just
really didn't see coming even though
these things
are you know planned out in the calendar
yes and they are the same every year
i know they never change but yet but
they always feel different snuck up on
us
it's really summer it's 70 degrees and
sunny the construction has
officially moved away from our window so
we are feeling very grateful
humble nice and quiet and we have a
great show i mean it's wednesday that
means steer toasters and we have
an update for you guys which we're
really excited about that'll be later in
the show
we've got the real housewives of new
york recap and we have so many other
recaps because
so much happened over the weekend the
friends reunion there was just
lots to unpack i watched so much tv we
have the friends reunion as a story but
i finished the big shot with bethany
okay spoiler alert
do you want to know who won did you
watch any of it yeah i watch like four
episodes
it gets like less and less like i mean
if it's not the person who i want it to
be i
don't know her name i forget her name
yeah
don't okay you know what i'll watch it i
really hope she won honestly i watch it
i
it did end up being like a big fat
[ __ ] waste of time like it was funny
in the beginning i think that it wasn't
gonna be
in the beginning i was living for it and
then it just got like
she was so chaotic she brought people
back fired people new person like
there was no structure to the show and
she had said that in the beginning like
that's just the type of business person
she is
and i respect that but like as a tv show
like i need a little bit more structure
i hear you i'm probably good like i'll
watch it at some point i didn't watch
any tv this weekend i was reading
by the way new episode of the redheads
drops tomorrow we're recording it
tonight so get your questions in the
redheads book club
gmail.com i did not plan my reading
calendar properly and i started a
book on the plane on the way to dallas
and i was like looking for a book to
read and i should have [ __ ] started
the red heads book
because i didn't even get to finish the
other one now i'm starting right i'm 50
and the book is so good i know i have to
speed through it so it's like i want to
enjoy it but i
can't this is claire crawley energy it's
just very chaotic so chaotic and so
but for you guys like you should read
the book and enjoy it and then listen to
the episode when it drops
yeah um i didn't get a chance to read
really much this weekend either it was
busy you know did you finish that book
uh where the grass is green
no i made it about 30 we made it about i
made it 28
when i decided no thank you yeah i
um what's it called where the grass is
green and the girls are pretty
first of all i didn't had no idea what
it was about so when i learned it was
kind of like an adaptation of a real
life you know scandal the college
admissions scandal i was like oh
it's kind of like a played out scandal
already and it's only like two years old
and then like the daughter right when i
ended it the daughter i put up a vlog
before she knew like her dad was
arrested spoiler alert
and i was like this is like olivia jade
i was just like
i don't know part of me like feels like
hasn't olivia jade been through enough
like we're gonna really be like you know
punching her again making her like the
but i don't know if that's what the book
is about like
vlog yeah but i was just getting like
olivia jade vibes and i was just like
the story has been told
many times yeah i was good i was good
without it it just wasn't for me so
it's been like just a crazy week of
reading for me
yeah it's been like a crazy week of
travel for me i did survive and i am
here therefore you will not have to look
for replacements
oh i'm glad but i am glad that i gave
him you know my eulogy just in case
because i really do want to make you
feel prepared and you probably felt very
much at peace
at peace because i'm like i have like a
last will and testament on this last
episode
if anything happens to me you know you
know who to replace me with everyone
knows how much i've loved my time here
but i made it so the eulogy was really
for nothing um but it really was
very scary i have flown to the hamptons
one time before and i refuse to take a
helicopter i just don't
[ __ ] with that but seaplanes are more
safe
because they fly over the water than
helicopters and i hadn't taken it in a
few years and the second i got on the
plane i had like a reminder of the
feeling i had deja vu of the feeling i
had when i first took it
and how i made a promise to myself that
first time that i would never do it
again
yet here i was doing it again and i was
like i'm so mad at myself i literally
wanted to get off
it was so scary and i flew with tpg
obviously and he was
cool as a cucumber like this man it was
crazy how he was
completely unphased it was unnatural you
know like the takeoff is so bumpy on the
water
it was a gorgeous day too like there
shouldn't have been an ounce of
turbulence but it was literally like
a soda can shaking it up before you like
it was
so chaotic but at the end of the day it
was door-to-door service in an hour like
how can you beat that to the hamptons on
memorial day weekend
yeah but the price is high it's your
life potentially
yeah you know how expensive price you
know how i felt about it i know which
was that
i just didn't think it was it was an
unnecessary treacherous risk on a
treacherous road but it rained the whole
weekend and the only nice day in the
hamptons that was like
pool weather was thursday and if i'd
drone out i wouldn't have drove out i
wouldn't have made it to like three four
o'clock so i ended up getting there at
11
and i had the whole day to swim i don't
know if i can tell maybe i got a little
tan
like it was it does look tan and then it
rained for three days straight which i
was talking about how like i was having
a lot of anxiety about like all the
chaos that would ensue in the hamptons
if the weather was nice and i literally
didn't see anyone because it rained the
whole time oh nice you bypassed it i
you know what i really wasn't upset
that's nice yeah i'm happy for you
i'm happy you had the best of both
worlds i did i really did it was a
lovely weekend
nice to be with tpg take some time off
very nice
and i made it back alive and that's at
the end of the day truly all that
matters
all you can ask for all you can hope for
um
i was at my sister-in-law's wedding this
weekend which was so beautiful
and so much fun and now i'm like sick
can you tell my voice
yeah okay i don't know because i don't
know what i sound like which is why i
think i have a beautiful singing voice
um no i caught a cold in the middle of
the party like
and then i've just been like having a
cold ever since
there's like this thing going around
like post covid i saw
i had it and i gave it to you and then i
think you also gave it to margo
and sorry snatcher and then i saw it on
tick tock like a lot of people are
getting like mysterious cults it's like
you think it's allergies it's not
covered
i just think it's like this postcopy
thing where we've been in our houses for
so long like not exposed to any germs
like
you go on the subway and you immediately
catch like this weird cold that's going
around
yeah definitely and i also think that
just with the seasons changing like it
happens but i i thought i already paid
my
dues to the cold man yeah you know like
two weeks ago when i had a cold but here
i am with another one but i think i'm on
the down part of it i think i already
passed the hump which is good but now i
just have this sticky sticky
shoes my sticky sticky shoes
we have to talk about the friends okay
do you want to talk about it yeah i mean
is it a story
it is a story so we should talk about it
and do you want to show everyone when i
got you speaking of the friends reunion
i got her a little present because i'm
always thinking of her jackie went to
ulta and found the friends x makeup
revolution
collab and while i don't i didn't like
die for any of the palettes i don't
really even wear eye shadow
they made a mirror that's a lobster he's
her lobster
so it's a handheld mirror and i'm so
excited because i love using handheld
mirrors
and it's a big-ass one you can really
never have enough you can't have enough
so i was just always thinking of you
always wondering like what would claudia
what what what what what what what's
happy like how can i brighten claudia's
day that is like so nice because like i
love you but i don't really think that
but then when you told me you got me
something i was like oh my god i should
get her something but i literally did
not leave my house no
you don't need to get me something i
just would like to see you bring it home
from the studio
i'll bring this home 100 like because
you know the the inner peace puzzle that
i got her is still here at the studio
and that [ __ ] cuts deep well because
you just never know like when we're
gonna get you know like locked in here
or something and we'll need to do a
puzzle you know
yeah you i guess you never know you
never know and i'm constantly
being prepared like preparedness is one
of my personality traits
okay cool yeah cool um so sorry i didn't
get you anything
no that's not why i did it don't get
gifts like with an expectation
for someone to get you something like i
guess but that's pretty much the only
reason to get someone to give
you know like i know that's not true
about you no it's not i do like giving
gifts but i'm sure if you saw something
that just screamed me like you would get
it
but you just haven't been moved like
that i also just don't go anywhere like
that's the hard part you know
yeah and if i do go somewhere it's like
just to get like drinks and you don't
really even drink anymore so what am i
gonna do get you like
bring me back a drink like a sparkling
water
um i i got home on monday
and i had such a traumatic day yesterday
it was
top 10 one of the worst days in the
years i am aware
there was a lot of rain in manhattan
over the last couple days i was gone
from my house for about
five days and when i woke up on tuesday
morning i went to the kitchen
to make myself a coffee and i was gonna
do a whole coffee review and what do i
see on my kitchen floor
i see a quote-unquote water bug it's a
roach
dead on its back and i'm like holy [ __ ]
like
that's one of those things where your
earth like the wall like
it just it shatters everything so i run
into the bedroom to get my phone
and then i'm like what is that under my
chair like something caught my eye
another roach belly up
so i'm like holy [ __ ] it's an
infestation
and so i took a couple pictures i called
my handyman to help me
uh dispose of them because i really just
could not do it and then
i had to call an exterminator an
exterminator that i
i have i'm we're very on top of our
extermination needs like i have an
exterminator come once a month
but um i couldn't get in touch with him
so i just called like a random company
and they couldn't get there till seven
so i had to wait this was like 11 a.m i
had to wait from like 11 a.m till 7 like
in a home that i felt
personally victimized by like i sat the
entire day in the middle of my bed
so that like no you know bug could like
crawl up my leg or something like i sat
in the middle of my bed i had had
plans to have such a productive day i
did not do one thing i was like
i was fearing for my life in my own home
and it's just the worst
[ __ ] feeling was theo there yes but
like he was just like kind of feeding
off of my energy which was very
you know terrorized so
the exterminator came you know we laid
the traps we sprayed we didn't find any
more which was good
they say they say things to make you
feel better you know like when it rains
and the types of roads
that's true also when the types of uh
roaches that i have water bugs are
excuse me are very common when it rains
a lot and they can come up your drains
so
they said the fact that they were dead
is great means there's not an
infestation it just means like you know
someone else exterminated them from
their home and they came to your house
to die like
so i don't really know what to do about
it i feel so unsafe in my own home and
there's no worse feeling than that
there's only one thing you can do really
and that's move no i think i can also
burn my house down
and take actually roaches can survive
like a nuclear war right yeah
you just have to move i think the
solution for you is on street easy
yeah and i think it's time for you to go
i mean you've had a wonderful time there
but it's become
clear that this place is not for you
well i
listen i have been wanting to move i've
been talking about that for like a few
months
and if i find something i will move but
i made peace like literally
two weeks ago i'm like i'm not gonna
move i just made a large
you know i just spent a large sum of
money on something and i was like
to kind of reconcile that i was like i'm
not gonna move therefore you know like
it all evens out even though like it
definitely doesn't
um and now i'm i'm left with a true
deandra's choice
because i have to move or i have to like
burn my entire building down no but then
you still would have to move because you
wouldn't have a place to live so why
should the building suffer
that's true why can't you just leave and
then i could like would be potentially
putting others in danger
right and then like i'm sure like the
insurance company would see this episode
like
fraudulent fraudulent we know who did it
fraudulent yeah
so i'm in a tough spot i really am and i
just
i can't sleep like you know when you
feel like a mouse on you but there's
like nothing there i just woke up
feeling very irritated
it's been a true nightmare like to be me
yeah no i
i feel that and so i mean i personally
really like roadway i think they're a
great moving company
um and we i'll send you links if of
apartments if i see them
please do it's just like so frustrating
because i'm like you know what now i
need to move out of the city like
yes because the city is just filled with
like roaches and
rats and mice but it's like no matter
where you go
there are regional rodents you know like
like
huntsville everyone has cicadas and
snakes alligators yeah wait
did you see the mouse at whole foods
excuse me no
at whole foods in manhattan anyone see
this and you know how they have um like
those displays of meat like because they
have a butcher there
um there was a mouse like nibbling on
the meat in the glass case
at wholesale oh i did see that that's
disgusting
i did so it's time to leave new york
city
no but i feel like there's time so many
people running for mayor now
and none of them are really kind of
addressing like wanting to tackle this
particular
issue and of course there's so many
issues in the city like where does one
be where do you begin
but i do feel like there's something
that needs to be done about like the
incessant rodent problem
yeah i don't know what what that is but
you know what i also feel like i feel
like while we were all at home for the
year like
locking down the rodents and the pigeons
like
they ruled this town yes their town and
they're not going home now they work too
hard for this zip code
to go home now and they're not going
home now and so i feel like now that the
people are back out again it's like
we're encountering all of gang violence
like
literally the two gangs like fighting
for turf you're 100
right like remember a year ago there was
those stories about like the super rats
because it was
it was a ratty rat world so the rats
only the strongest survived and now
that's who we're up against yeah i'm
telling you you guys are going to start
encountering more and more of these
creatures more and more rad violence
no it's [ __ ] terrible and i really i
know there's a mayoral race coming up
and i don't feel like any canada is
really tackling this issue
i feel like the mayoral race hasn't
heated up yet i've been like i haven't
been
all in on paying attention i just hear
like things here and there i think
barbara cave of it
uh barbara cavett i see some commercials
um but i do feel like
after the summer things are really going
to heat up because it is a little early
still but i really look forward to
seeing what everybody
has to put up to bring to the table i'm
really really excited and if anybody
wants to you know get into the hearts of
millions of new yorkers like let's start
talking about the true issues of our
city
the rodents yeah that's just a
suggestion among the others
amongst the millions there's honestly
it's daunting i don't know who would
want to be mayor of new york like we
have so many problems
yeah we're inheriting like the worst
city the worst the city's been in years
yeah so good luck to everyone we'll be
paying attention i'm really excited to
see what you guys bring to the table
pay attention please um we have an
amazing show i really feel like we
should just jump right in i think we
should get
right into the fast five stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
bluenile.com at bluenile.com you can
celebrate all of life's special moments
from creating custom engagement ring of
her dreams
to gifting a once-in-a-lifetime piece
all at prices you will never you won't
find at a traditional
jeweler so bluenile.com has the most
stunning
fine jewelry you can buy it for yourself
as a gift
you can buy it for someone else as a
gift there's never a bad time
a wedding an anniversary they can
personalize
pretty much anything and it's really
really all stunning so whether you're
marking a milestone or celebrating in
general
bluenyle.com offers fine jewelry perfect
for every occasion
you can mark the moment with something
timeless like classic diamond stud
earrings an elegant tennis bracelet
birthstone pendants and so much more you
can easily navigate thousands of
gemstone options at bluenile.com
and they have every price point so from
textured gold to multi-colored gemstones
and classic pearls you can shop this
season
stunning trends on bluenile.com they
have a huge
uh selection of preset diamond jewelry
so you never have to settle
you can choose from more than a hundred
thousand ethically sourced gia grade
diamonds in every shape and size with an
endless selection of settings to help
you design the rings earrings or pendant
of your dreams they have legendary
services with expert advice 24 7
and 30 day returns so when you commit to
a piece so does blue nile they have
guaranteed service and repair
for life not for a limited time for life
so anything you get whether it's
earrings or jewelry they've guaranteed
repairs so whether you need it
you know fixed up whatever they got you
covered
and you have peace of mind because most
in most cases blue nile can deliver
overnight
every order is insured and it arrives in
discrete packaging that won't give away
what's inside
so make the moment sparkle with jewelry
from bluenile.com and the morning toast
listeners can get 50
off their purchase of over 500 this
podcast exclusive is only good for the
morning toast and you have to use code
toast that's t-o-a-s-t plus not perfect
no problem
shop stress-free free with guaranteed
free shipping and returns
find your forever piece go to
bluenile.com today and again that's 50
off your purchase of over 100 500 for uh
code
host t-o-i-s-t i'm the most gorgeous i
feel like retro meaners
it's gorgeous pair of gold diamond hoops
so that's literally what i have no then
they're like rainbow and they're so cute
they're so cute
the quality is unbeatable unmatched if
you're looking for something
so stellar free service and repairs for
life i mean that's just that's a deal
that's a deal okay first story friends
reunion here's how much money the cast
of friends made for the reunion versus
season one
okay so season one i don't know if you
know this they each made about 22
hundred dollars per episode okay which
is pretty good do you wanna go through
every season or do you just wanna know
where you
know they were the first people um on tv
to make a million dollars an episode
yeah so then season two they reportedly
made between 22 500 and forty thousand
and at the time rachel and ross were
making more than the others really
yes but then at season three they all
were making about seventy five thousand
dollars
jennifer aniston said in an interview
the negotiations at the time she said
the negotiations were more about
we're doing equal work and we all
deserve to be compensated in the same
way
i wouldn't feel good going to work
knowing someone was getting x amount and
i was getting something greater
and also like she wasn't better than
anyone or more
of a star than anyone else like they
really all and that's what i really
liked about the friends reunion
was they gave such a like an interesting
so i know a lot of people were like not
happy with it because i think they
wanted like
an episode yeah and that's what i was
expecting as well but i can't even
explain like how relieved i was that it
wasn't that
one because it wouldn't have been good
yeah and two
they gave a very clear explanation james
corden asked like if they would do
a um like a movie or like another you
know reunion special
and they were like no and the creators
basically explained like they tied up
the show
in such a nice way like everyone really
got tucked away nicely you know monica
and chandler moved to the suburbs
phoebe met mike who was paul rudd who
was not there which was very bizarre
like his absence was felt
um rachel and ross finally got back
together and joey was like you know
being joey
and why would they unravel that in order
to have a storyline like
it gives people who love the show peace
of mind like everyone is living their
best lives
in connecticut you know and also what
they had said was that
the premise of the show was that time in
your life where your friends are your
family
and the show ended at a time where like
they were all having babies
getting married where like your family
is your family so for the show
friends to exist in a time other than
those like special seven years
is not the point and then they also said
back to my original point was that
the show was like the first of its kind
to have an ensemble cast like everyone
was a star there wasn't it wasn't the
rachel show it wasn't the jennifer
anderson joe
it was really and that's why people are
like i'm a phoebe i'm a because everyone
related in some way even ensemble shows
like
sex in the city like carrie's the star
like you really can't say who the star
of i mean i could if i wanted to but who
do you think
well i did read an article once like who
was the star of friends and based on how
much time they had
time they had and dialogue and the
person who had the most time and
dialogue was ross and i actually would
agree that ross
um maybe not the star but was like
it's just a personality thing like i
think that phoebe and
ross were so perfectly cast and what's
crazy
is that and the special they went
through the casting
thing and the producers of the show the
creators had known david trimmer before
for like a
an audition and they didn't think he was
right for it but they thought he was
hilarious
and so they wrote ross for him and
that's why i feel like ross is
so ross because the role was like
literally written kind of how like evan
hansen was written for ben platt you
know so it's so rough
and phoebe and they didn't mention this
in the special which i thought was weird
but
phoebe's character was cast as ellen
degeneres
and then something happened and ellen
got her own show or something and she
gave up the role and lisa kudrow got it
so but for me like
phoebe made lisa kudrow made phoebe so
her own it also felt like
it was written for her but it wasn't
yeah so there was like interesting
tidbits in the whole special
um but sorry back to your article they
made three million dollars each right
they made about two and a half million
dollars each yeah and then when the
credits rolled they were all
also executive producers so they
definitely made more than that yeah even
more than that
and initially they were offered a
million dollars each but they turned
that down
really so what were your thoughts on the
special i really liked it i mean don't
get me wrong like
i'm so negative so there were so many
moments that like was we're so losery
like
and i liked that it was long and i felt
like i wish more of the air time was
dedicated to like you know more bloopers
more you know
tom selleck showed up like more guest
stars
but they had so many like celebrities
just kind of like explaining what
friends meant to them and i just like
honestly like
david beckham like you know he travels
all the time and like when he gets in
his hotel room like he watches friends
it makes him feel at home and like
that's actually how i feel like when i'm
on the road and like i
watch friends like i feel like i'm back
in my bedroom like i really relate to
that
but i just don't care you know and then
i was like mindy kaling
love you don't care and then you know
they had malala and her friend and they
were like this is why we're friends
sweet don't care like there was just so
much like
unnecessary like celebrity moments so
they had this segment like
iconic um outfits from friends like
where certain episodes like ross says
this episode about his leather pants
where he's on a date with a girl he's
wearing these tight pants and he goes to
pee and he can't get his pants back on
and they have a fashion show like all
the iconic
fashion um and like cara delevingne
modeled in it cindy crawford modeled in
it justin bieber modeled in it
and like okay yes maybe a good idea on
paper but
i so didn't care like i'm just like take
me back to the friends like yeah i feel
like they just wasted so much time on
things that weren't about the six cast
mates
and james corden got a lot of you know
people just don't like james corden and
um i actually do like him and i thought
he did a fine job he didn't bother me
like
making it about himself like which a lot
of people do
um but there were great moments so i
don't want to focus on the negative ones
because overall i was like
really entertained the whole time i was
a little upset we didn't get any paul
rudd who is the guy who ended up with
phoebe
um but they did have tom selleck come on
which was just delightful like margot
i was watching in margaret she was like
losing her mind
um they had gunther who like couldn't
make it so he was on via zoom and i'm
like
they're like get on the plane like yeah
the biggest thing you've
ever done like get on the plane um and
then they had janice too
and it was just nice to see like how
they all interacted with
like these celebrities um and they all
seem like really nice people like i
don't know
i don't think there's any you know diva
like behavior going on because everyone
they seem like really good friends and
they were so nice to everyone like they
remembered everyone's names like it was
just like nice and they were all getting
emotional and it was sweet
i did get like a little choked up at the
end because it was just like really
sweet
it was i actually really liked it and i
was surprised that a lot of people
didn't like it because it just wasn't
what people were expecting
yeah but i think it's like a great new
format like not everything needs to be a
reboot like sometimes it's nice to just
get together and chat yeah and that's
what it was now there's a lot of stories
like being
published about matthew perry yes i was
gonna ask you
so did i think he sounded weird
yes did he act weird no and so this
the story that he came out and said is
that like he had major dental surgery
a few days before and that's why he
sounded weird zac efron tried it you
guys
no i know but i do have to say like he
wasn't acting bizarre he was just
sounding bizarre so like the dentist
story like kind of tracks like
but they also he was like barely in it
like he didn't say anything so i feel
like maybe they cut a lot of his stuff
out like and i just think people are
worried because he's openly
you know struggled with addiction and
he's sober and he even had a tv show
right about
like um yeah also i read this morning
that him and his fiance broke up
yes so maybe he's just going through a
tough time and it wasn't great timing
for him
yeah i'm sad i don't believe dental
surgery like
again hasn't worked had the biggest
thing in the years we're gonna go to
get our but he also did have like big
teeth so like no to do it like
a week before the special of a lifetime
you're getting paid two and a half
million dollars
and two and a half million dollars to
these people is absolutely nothing no
some of them i think that's a big day no
literally
like every year when there are these
lists of like top
paid tv they're on it every year just
for like syndication
and netflix but they're making like just
in like licensing and royalties and this
this stupid collab you know like they're
making like
20 million dollars a year i'm the sucker
who bought it it's fabulous
but they're fine financially i know but
two and a half million dollars like
don't get your teeth done
a week before 100 that's what happened
and it's not
yeah so there's just like something
going on there he was just giving me
like sad vibes you know i feel like
everyone was really really excited to be
there
um and the one like i don't even
remember anything he said memorably
except for that
they filmed in front of a live studio
audience and they really said like that
was it was like basically doing like
like a theater every night and it really
made you want to like do better and have
the joke land
and matthew perry's character and i
guess he was kind of like this in real
life he's like joke
joke joke shows like he's just like an
annoying jokester you know
and if he said a joke that you know the
audience in real life like didn't laugh
at like it really chipped away at him
and he was like really struggling with
that
and everyone when he said that just went
kind of like quiet
and phoebe was like you never told us
that like it was just
obvious that he struggled with a lot
internally on the show
yeah stuff we know about and stuff we
also didn't know about so he was just
giving me like sad energy and i like
actually felt sad for him because he
really
did not say anything yeah that's really
sad i i mean i'm with him i think the
studio audience had to go
that's my biggest gripe but you know
like the laugh track that they i think
that they use in the show is not the
studio audience because like
i don't i just it wasn't matching up for
me like you know what i mean
yeah i hear you um but i i did love it
and i just wish we talked a little bit
more about like
you know what's been going on with them
like it's taken them so because at the
end they were like what have you taken
away from this experience and they were
like
it shouldn't ever be this long before
we're all in a room together again and i
know that the girls hang out and i think
that there's a lot of weirdness
i i just what i've heard is that it
comes from like david schwimmer but he
was like being like so
friendly but like maybe he's just a good
actor yeah there was i just wanted to
know like
well why haven't you guys like been
together and why have you there been so
much like weird rumors like what's the
truth
yeah we weren't getting into that i
understand one other little bombshell
that they did drop is that rachel and
ross like in
real life were like majorly crushing on
each other the first few seasons
um and it was just like bad timing
because like she was in a relationship
then he was in a relationship and so
they never actually got together
but and their first kiss like was on the
show which was weird
but it ended up being so great like if
they had been together none of the cast
dated at all which is like kind of
rare um and that perhaps is why the show
was so successful for so long because
when people break up it gets weird then
they have to date in the show but then
they want it you know
yeah it never ended up dating so it
never created any sort of like weirdness
and it actually ended up being for the
best
interesting that was like maybe i'm like
you're both single now are you like
maybe we i don't know if they are i
don't know who david trimmer like does
in his personal life but
i'm like i don't know maybe now's the
time yeah i mean they all are
like so old like it's crazy like seeing
the bloopers and then
because they look the same but they look
so different yeah yeah
interesting okay i'm glad you liked it i
loved it like honestly i would watch it
again oh
and another cameo that was excellent
that i
what didn't mind probably the only one
was lady gaga
she came with phoebe and they performed
smelly cat
and then they had this gospel choir come
which is like a reference to an old
episode and it was
so funny and then lady gaga made this
like nice little speech basically phoebe
was like you know the weird quirky one
she was into like tarot cards and [ __ ]
and lady gaga was like thank you so much
for being like you know
the different one and like making it
cool to be weird and then
lisa cruz was like oh my god that's so
nice thank you man and thank you for
carrying that on it was like a
passing of the church it was lovely it
was really cute there were a few cute
sweet moments there was definitely some
losery ones like cam tonight like
honestly cindy crawford
should know better like it was really
embarrassing for her um cara delevingne
too not once but she came out on the
runway twice like she was the only model
who went twice like it was
it was loser yeah i'm not gonna lie all
the models like models that we know
yeah no there was like only the thing is
it was a fashion show with four looks
cara delevingne
cara delevingne justin bieber and sydney
city crawford oh and then
matt perry did one which was funny um it
was just like there were a lot of things
taking me away from the cast i'm like no
let's bring it back
got it that's who we are all here for
we've waited 17 years like let's bring
it back
got it that's really funny okay cool
thank you for that very in-depth recap i
feel like i watched it and justice for
paul rod like where the [ __ ] was he well
he could have i'm sure he could have
been there so it's just this for
everybody else that he wasn't there
yeah like i'm sure he wasn't yeah they
even had monica and monica and ross's
parents who
were old on the show and now they're
from massapequa yeah no that's where
their engagement party was but they're
from
actually they might be from massapequa
because it sounds like a magical place
why else would they get engaged there
not engagement sorry anniversary party
why yes is it steeped in native american
history
actually i watched that episode
yesterday with alec baldwin oh and alex
baldwin wasn't there
they did a whole series on like the most
famous people who were on the show
because they couldn't believe like
you know they were working with some of
their idols so sean penn was on it
charlie sheen and then they mentioned
david trimmer was like and your guy brad
pitt it was
so awkward oh my god yeah um she was
like yeah
and so they were like kind of rattling
off all the iconic people before they
were famous and after denise richards
has been on
rebecca romain gabrielle union like so
many people they didn't mention alec
baldwin
that's weird yeah especially because
like i think a lot of the
friends fandom like regards that episode
as like one of the best
it's so funny yeah it's funny when you
tell me about it
oh my god just watch it i watched the
math piqua episode no no just watch the
show
i've tried yo you don't want me we're
not doing this i'm not gonna take away
from your
happy occasion i really enjoyed it and i
think i got i got pretty much everything
i wanted out of it i'm so glad
except you know you're a loser when they
like were doing all these bloopers and
like i've literally seen them all
because i watch the videos on youtube
like
that's losery of me so i had seen like
half of the uh
the content okay it was good it was good
are you ready for our next story
theo looks so [ __ ] deliciously cute
he is so delicious and cute he's kicking
me he said he's ready for the next story
he started his new
um walker today so i think he's just
like spent
oh yeah he had his big time exercise but
he has
bruce exercise today too he's excited
i'm excited for him he kicked me he's
time for the next story he said next
[ __ ] story stuff i'm talking about
this dumb [ __ ] show
okay miles teller's wife corroborates
the claim that he was jumped by two
strangers in hawaii
so this is a really crazy story that
emerged this weekend the tellers are
telling their side of a complicated
story
they are the tellers they are the
tellers surrounding the alleged assault
of actor miles teller
while initial reports of the altercation
claim that miles
was slugged by a man claiming he owed
him sixty thousand dollars
both teller and his wife kelly claimed
he was actually jumped by two strangers
kelly wrote on instagram the story
reported about miles being punched in
the face by tmz over money
is completely false miles was jumped by
two men we have never met
after they trapped him in a bathroom it
seems these same men have done this to
many people and we appreciate your
support maui
this is now a criminal investigation
right so they were married in hawaii and
i guess people were
saying that like they had unpaid wedding
bills which like he's in top gun i don't
think that's the case
i don't think that's the case but it's
just really crazy how this vacation went
from like
yes paradise to hell to hell
no literally like last time we spoke we
were talking about chalene and her
shorts and
and shortlists of it all and chains if
only if shaylene's mysterious shorts
were the biggest drama of the trip
no i mean never a dull moment when
you're shortlist yeah of course
and so i'm just i'm scary to be locked
in about how scary and now this
trip like obviously they'll have a pit
about it forever and it started out so
lovely on a hike with the waterfalls
that's just like what life is like highs
and lows you know what i mean sometimes
they happen in the same weekend
yeah sometimes you get canceled and
engaged on the same day on the same damn
day on the same
evening like sometimes that's just how
life works because you know what they
say
man plans god laughs and you can be
happy and sad at the same time thank you
casey muskraves for so
acutely actually summing that up thank
you
i don't know what acutely means no you
were good too oh yeah okay yeah you were
very acute about it
i'm so cute you look so cute today thank
you
um but back to the story like very scary
very sad and also like the
misinformation
assuming that like what they're saying
is true and and what tmz were probably
false
i believe i believe them too but it's
just like not only do you get beat up
but then you also have rumors about you
right like you didn't pay dodging your
bills like you know
uh withholding money from small vendors
like
that is traumatizing in and of itself
right along with
all the salaciousness so i'm glad she
just set the record straight yeah
took it does my instagram i feel like no
i think he does so
she's speaking for both of them i'm sure
and and we like to see
that a little direct communication i do
i love to see like
celebrities whether it's reality stars
influencers just cutting
out like the middle man you know like
not not giving an interviewer statement
to tmz like that they can like
discombobulate like here's what happened
check it out check my ig and don't
forget to follow me
totally and here's another celebrity
instagram comment
making news um amy schumer has been
taken to instagram
like on a weird one she's been taking to
instagram to share some of her thoughts
on things
and movies that she's seen and people
can't tell if she's joking
but we believe that she is she is amy
schumer took to instagram to recommend a
quiet place part two
starring emily bunt blunt and directed
by john krasinski emily bundt cake
he's a bun cake and john krasinski who
also happened to be married she raved
about the movie
the sequel to the 2018 horror film she
said i loved every second of a quiet
place movie even better than the first
one which blew me away
amazing to be in a movie theater i've
said this for a long time i think emily
and john have a pretend marriage for
publicity but i still
think you should see it this rainy
weekend okay so
that's pretty funny um she made two
jokes and then the other one was she i
guess she also
took in cruella this weekend starring
emma stone she said did a busy content
weekend
she said it's well known emma stone is a
toxic person but disney cruella is
amazing
okay so this one i felt like was so
obviously a joke the other
because i feel like i remember stories
about them hanging out
yes with jennifer lawrence yeah and yeah
adele adele yes
so i i have like faint you know memory
of them being friends and this to me is
like so clearly a joke
whereas the other one i feel like really
could have been serious like it was it's
funny but it's also like i
could see her saying that right at first
when i saw just like a screenshot of it
without context i was like oh amy
schumer's like out here
like speaking her speaking facts like
yeah all cap no but no john christensen
responded thank you amy for blowing up
our whole marriage spot
yeah okay that's not a good response but
um like
learn how the kids talk blowing up our
whole marriage spot i think you mean
blowing up our spot
i just like i don't want to think about
it too hard so because it could have
been so much better you know like they
actually probably spent time
like with the prt communicating how
we're gonna respond to this you know
media blitz
yeah we've gotta be like cool with the
kids and that's what they came up with
and it's just not good enough no not at
all but i
did i i did find it funny but also at
first i was like a little confused
and i don't know i just love that like
she's
like truly does not care like she didn't
clarify she didn't do a follow-up she's
like interpret this as you will
yeah and she's not like oh sorry guys
like it was a joke yeah no it's just
like figure it out she's a comedian so
emma stone may or may not be a toxic
person right no we never
we truly never know though i my
professional opinion is that these are
jokes yes me too as somebody in the
comedy space i think i can say with with
somewhat certainty that these are
definitely jokes and they're pretty
funny and they're funny ones
speaking of both of those movies i do
plan on seeing both of them mm-hmm
um i heard cruella was great and i
actually saw tick tock do you know why
they um
released it on may 28th um
i'm trying to think of a good enough
reason it's cameron boyce's birthday
and he played corellia in descendants
yeah
wow that's really sweet that's really
sweet
and i can't believe that they're like
have such ties to descendants you know
the disney family it is the disney
family but i just feel like even though
descendants it's such an amazing idea
like the descendants of the villains
um that it doesn't actually tie in to
the actual movie
no like and where where do we see
cruella pregnant
you know that's such a good cause
like where is the connection yeah no
that's such a good call you literally
never know
um but maybe we'll find out in the movie
maybe there's a man in her life
so i want to see that and i actually do
want to see a quiet place because i saw
a quiet place one
um i know abe was watching that this is
one of my favorites watching it on the
plane
but claudia was sitting next to him and
so she was like watching over his
shoulder the whole time which was
actually perfect
it's a silent film it's a silent film
she didn't need to i didn't need his
headphones yeah and so then he text me
like do you want to see the second one
together and i was like yeah oh cute
just like how you watch the first one
yeah
so we're gonna take a trip to bogota and
we're i'm just gonna watch it over his
shoulder
very sweet so i'm gonna plan on seeing
both them and i heard they were both
really good
okay cool yeah i want to see cruella
it's interesting how like a quiet place
was like the first movie to get
cancelled
before covent and now it's finally back
like it's literally a full-blown year
and a half
yeah yeah crazy such is life okay next
story is a little
book news book news brought to you by
honey yes
we i think we all shop online
and we've seen that promo code field
taunt us at checkout but thanks to honey
manually searching for coupon codes is a
thing of the past
honey is the free shopping tool that
scours the internet for promo codes and
applies the best ones it finds
to your car they support over 30 000
stores they range from sites that sell
tech and gaming products
to popular fashion brands even food
delivery i've used it on makeup clothing
you can really use it on anything
here's how it works you're shopping at
one of your favorite websites and when
you check out the honey button just
mysteriously drops down
and all you have to do is click apply
coupons you wait a few seconds as honey
searches for coupons you can find for
that site
and if they find a working coupon you'll
watch the price drop like that
i've saved money on so many things it's
honestly just a no-brainer at this point
it's just a part of my online shopping
routine
it's such a fabulous browser extension
it's free to download
and they have found over 17 million
members over two billion dollars in
savings so if you don't already have
honey you are missing out on free
savings it's free to install
and downloads in just a few seconds by
getting it you'll be doing yourself a
solid and by using our link you'll be
supporting the toast
so you can get honey for free at
joinhoney.com
toast that's join honey dot com slash
toast
check it out i mean honestly just check
it out like check it out
sign on everything of the sort there is
no downside and
it's one of those things once you have
it you'll be like oh wow
i should have been doing this sooner
yeah okay next story a little book news
el james is talking about her new book
freed it's the newest book in the 50
shade series
and it comes from the perspective of
christian gray
hitting bookstore shelves on tuesday is
her latest novel freed which is the
sixth book in the fifty shades
series it talks about a six week gap
while they're preparing for their
wedding
but it's very you know um what's that
book
like twilight but the new one midnight
sun yeah midnight sun
where finally we're hearing from
christian's perspective about how anna's
defiant spirit continues to stir
christians darkest fears and tests his
need for control
so i guess like understanding why he's a
freak yeah i have been wondering because
i haven't read the books but i saw the
movie and honestly i found dakota
johnson to be so annoying
so i can't imagine like reading a book
from her perspective because she was
like such a weenie
yeah um so no but also when you watch
the movies it's like this man like he's
so
troubled and he just mysteriously
disappears for like long periods
yeah it's like where is he going what is
he doing so i guess reading it from his
perspective and like the backstory of
his childhood and all this stuff like
we'll
answer some questions i don't know this
just like
the book and the movie i read the book
and then i saw the first movie and
that's as much as i saw and i just felt
like the movie didn't
do the book justice i thought it was
honestly one of the worst casted
franchises
ever and it's weird because i like
considered the ad up the movie
adaptation like kind of a failure even
though it's like gross 1.3 billion
i still don't think it was a good one
it's not kind of like regarded as iconic
money is money because it has a huge
cult following people were gonna see it
but people don't go back and re-watch it
like they do twilight or people don't
know
unless it's like it's only just ever
playing on e like yes movies we love aka
movies we got the licenses too
not love literally i've only seen it
once because it was on e-movies we have
movies we have the licensing rights but
we're going to force you to love
no 100 and i don't know if you guys read
my book i actually met el james and her
husband
who made the movie i did have some notes
for them
um and did she say anything like about
that relates to this story in particular
no but is like who did it first
midnight's
run midnight sun came out last year so
um
i want to say like i guess this is
exciting
stephanie meyers this came out first
stephanie meyers is her name oh is this
the third one from christian's
perspective
oh oh wow people just keep eating oh my
[ __ ] this is a cash cow if i was eating
james i would have also been writing
non-stop next i'm gonna write from the
dog's perspective
this will never stop no literally but i
actually like this is exciting for
people because
if you love the franchise like i love
twilight and i actually would like
love to read a book from edward's
perspective he's so mysterious you
should read twilight i know
next time you call me for a book wreck
twilight yeah i should i want to do it
too i just haven't so i think there are
people who would be excited to read this
from his perspective well there
definitely
are because she keeps writing these
books and also she told gma that like um
people come to her book signings and are
like i haven't read a book in 37 years
and then they like picked up 50 shades
and now they're like voracious readers
which is really nice it's a nice
entryway into reading
yeah i mean i think some people would
say that about girls on jobs book as
well yeah
no i heard people who hadn't read in 37
years love the book i heard people who
didn't even know how to read
learn to read because they heard my book
was so powerful this man right here
available at amazon barnes and noble and
really anywhere kindle nook all the
places once you read that book you must
listen to the episode on the redheads
where we sit down with the author and
ask her
most of the questions that you'll have
there's not that many that she leaves
with because she talks about everything
no stone under no stone she's turning
those stones constantly
constantly but you know there's a few
things here and they're lingering like
what happened with maverick yeah um and
we talk about it in the redheads and
then once you're a redhead that's a
great place to start
there's a world of opportunity for you
and is it
do you think it's possible to be like
too late to become a redhead no that's
the thing
it's never too late and sometimes you're
right on time it's beautiful because
depending on the book like i feel like
this book this month
is such a fabulous place to start a true
story fabulous woman
i'm loving the writing if you like
downton abbey if you it's just so good
if you liked
codename helene like following a real
heroine
i love heroin i know you do
i know you do you're going to love this
book it's called american duchess by
karen harper that would be a helpful
thing to know and
get your name as i continue to talk
about it um so happy for the el james
community
i am happy for them as well and i love a
little book news because we love to read
here at the toast and at the redheads we
do
we really do are ready for our fifth and
final story it's the final
[Music]
story
[Music]
okay now i feel ready honestly you guys
it's a little more cyber security
drama the ransom of it all it's a little
more cyber security ransom coming for
your daily needs okay
disgusting the meat industry is the
latest to be thrown into chaos by
ransomware
so clear crawly you guys remember the
colonial pipeline who could forget
the hacking of the colonial pipeline and
we were there on the ground in nashville
and
lines were long at the boots on the
ground boots on the ground we went
just to see how long the lines at the
pump were yeah and guess what the pumps
were closed
the pumps were quaking a ransomware
attack against the world's largest meat
processor is giving a taste of the chaos
hackers could cook up with a concerted
hack against the agricultural and food
sector
leave the farmers alone this is like so
crazy they're just coming for everything
everyone every industry every and like
next up there's gonna be a podcast hack
now it's probably so easy the attack
again don't give them ideas
the attack against brazil-based jbs has
halted production at all the company's
us meat processing facilities and
slaughterhouses across
australia shutting down one-fifth of u.s
beef production
production jbs said it expects to have
sufficiently recovered to have most
plants operational today
but the shutdown is still threatening a
temporary surge in beef and pork prices
and roiling an industry already battered
by the corona buyers pandemic
like honestly imagine being like that
cow that was supposed to be slaughtered
and then like some like it's like
literally like a life-saving hack
yeah and like he was next on the
conveyor belt but then like something
happened and he gets to like go back to
the farm
i can't wait to watch a movie about it
this is kind of like a stunning story
like i know like hacks are bad and
ransom like think of all like
the cows and and pigs that got like just
one more day to live
yeah it's it's kind of nice for them it
is
i guess but it's it's a girl's got to
eat it's concerning for the world at
large you know it's like who's next
first they came for the gas
then they came for the cows and then
they're coming for my neck
no you guys like this is crazy stuff and
it's just like change your password you
know
i guess i guess i just feel like we all
change our passwords more
we should that's also a good lesson to
take away unrelated to this i think
but do change your passwords and make
sure you have different passwords across
platforms
it's so hard it is hard how are you
supposed to remember that no
literally and then it's like okay i'll
create a word doc like with all my
passwords first of all you never
keep it updated that's exactly somebody
hacks the word doc and it's like
literally
all of your [ __ ] bad ideas you like
your social security number
that's a bad idea your routing number
it's so bad it's so hard
it's so stupid but we're thinking of the
meat industry
constantly today you need a burger
need yeah well you might might be more
expensive
if you could get one if i can get my
hands on one does this affect the kosher
meat industry at all
no it seemed like jbs was like they were
dealing with
pork and stuff right so that doesn't
include i guess my meat production is
not to make this about me but totally
unchanged
i don't know i mean you say that now
until they come forward
yeah oh until they come from the kosher
slaughterhouses
um okay so those were the fast five
stories and i definitely feel as though
um we were a little late to some of them
but some of them you definitely needed
to know more pressing
yeah for sure for sure i feel i like
when i woke up this morning
i'm not gonna like i've been so out of
touch all weekend that's like so
unplugged really
um and now i feel up to speed so i did
i didn't we didn't make it a story but i
just want to like indulge the people who
are following this tick tock drama
really quickly before we dive into the
tv and please explain it to me for those
who are listening who don't know either
okay
so there's this couple on tick tock okay
jack wright
he's one he's like a one of two twins
and they're like dancers and they're so
cute and
they blew up they were in the hype house
and
jack is his name his brother's name is
james it'll be important later on
jack started dating this girl sienna may
gomez who is like this body positive
um tick tocker she's super cute
and she blew up she's like 15 million
followers i think that they're all on
the high pass
netflix show i don't know how this
scandal affects that but
they've been dating for a while and once
a while in tick-tock terms
like i i i i already like i don't know
eight months like okay okay like a
decent amount of time and they're like
very you know showy on
online and yeah pda yeah
and recently i think a lot of people
have been like wondering what's going on
they stopped posting you know people
just like were you know loving to jump
to conclusions did they break up blah
blah
blah
then um also a little piece of backstory
these people also went to high school
together the twins in siena that's how
they knew each other and they kind of
all
came up together look at this tick tock
high school yeah no it's like deep
rooted
so one of their friends the friends of
the twins
posted and then deleted this like
statement on twitter it's so hard to see
your friend you know
be um in like a toxic relationship you
know trigger warning
saying that sienna was like sexually
assaulting
jack and telling him to kill himself
like all these
really insane allegations
and so people for like the last day were
just like
wilding out with this thing and james
who's the twins
other twin like you know made a tick
tock fanning the flames and
she's been losing hundreds of thousands
of followers people are just like coming
coming like
and so yesterday she spoke out for the
first time and
stated unequivocally that like
everything in that tweet which has since
been deleted is untrue
um that this whole relationship with
jack like she was manipulated
into thinking that it was a real
relationship like they never had sex
like he wouldn't even like
be with her i don't know and then the
real bombshell she said was like
she said i like i never sexually
assaulted jack and james the twin for
you to like fan the flames like
knowing what we know i think a lot of my
friends and my younger brother
would have you know a lot to say about
you
in this regard kind of subliminally
saying maybe there's some allegations
coming out about
james how old are these people
i mean i'm too old to know that's what
you're trying no they're like 18.
they literally just graduated high
school oh okay okay
okay continue so no then she left off
like very ominously kind of
you know alluding to but not really
saying anything about james
saying the whole relationship with jack
was like a lie and that all the
allegations coming out about her
are she refuse refutes them completely
okay so now people are just like well
where do we stand and i'm just too old
to be involved in this but i couldn't
help it like
it just it was insane and it was just
like non-stop
wow i don't know where we landed with
this like at all it sounds like it's
also developing and maybe we'll hear
from she only spoke out last night like
it's developing okay we'll see
yeah her ex the twins
they were in the same grade so oh so
they're all about their same age yeah
they literally just graduated high
school
okay cool it's crazy congratulations to
the graduates yes congrats
congrats so if you're following along
like me too and i just
it's crazy wow okay you'll keep us
abreast our tic-tac-toe
constantly let me think is there any
other tic doctor rama that needs to be
addressed
no um real housewives of new york was on
last night
yes get you a girl who can do both like
jack and sienna
ramona and luanne um it was a crazy
episode actually i did enjoy it like
there was
stuff happening you know um the ending
was kind of like where it all
went down but before that i know you
didn't watch i'll just give you like
yeah sorry guys i didn't watch because
like i said i'm in this like reading
i'm i'm behind on my homework i'm so
sorry that's okay it was
like um they just basically got ready
and went to luanne's house
ramona did say what happened to class oh
was it everything
no no no it was like basically what had
happened was she
at the dinner said to leah like i love
you so much but like
i just don't like when you talk like
that and i don't agree with ramona's
right to like police what people say
but it is ramona's house and she did
throw this dinner party and ramona
doesn't want you saying big [ __ ] suck
[ __ ] like that is her right even though
she's being like a little lame about it
like
i didn't agree with her last year in
mexico like yelling at leah every time
leah said penis
but especially when like ramona just
decides that and she's
it's like so sexual so it's not even
like it's so random
yeah it's so random and it is
hypocritical but if it's at ramona's
house everyone's staying at her house or
ramona through a dinner party
she's allowed to somewhat police what
people say she should but then just like
don't expect
people are going to come back or like be
nice to you so she basically said to
leah like i really don't like when
you're saying like [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then ebony was like not really
listening but then she was like
remember how can you say that i just
heard you say [ __ ] and
i heard you say like big cocker i like
big [ __ ] and ramona got really mad
because she's like that's not what i
said like
ebony took that out of context ebony
immediately apologized but it was just
like everyone was drunk and like being
chaotic
and you couldn't follow anything it was
like they woke up and everything was
fine sounds like the real houses of new
york
yeah they woke up and went to the wands
where they painted the naked man and all
the women were like funny i guess he had
like a huge penis
um and then they sat down to eat and
leah was just like in a bad place
all day she was like sobbing on ebony's
shoulder about her grandmother
kind of set in that she was really
probably never going to see her
grandmother again
and at this point i was just like go
home like
no one's forcing you to be here and if
your grandmother is
really like her time is so limited like
everyone would understand go
like yeah and she's not even having fun
she's not it's not taking her mind off
of it she just like can't get out of her
own
grief so i don't really understand why
she chose to stay but they go and sit
and have lunch and sonia is just like so
smart she stayed out of it
completely lee and ramona get into it
again leah just gets up and storms away
and the thing is is that ramona was
wrong because like if leah wants to talk
and be sex positive like
leave her alone like that has nothing to
do with you but then leah took it too
far
and was like ramona just kept saying you
know my daughter's 25 and she doesn't
talk like that and leah just like hates
being compared to ramona's daughter
and so she was like oh my god stop like
her and her friends are probably sucking
dick at 14
and it's like okay you can't say that
and then i don't know if anyone caught
this
leah storms away from the table and goes
to the front yard and it's just like
minding our business
and she's like god her [ __ ] i think
she said c-u-n-t
daughter she said oh her god daughter
like i'm like did you just say
i think that's what she said so she was
just like being like rude to avery
for no reason like avery wasn't even
there but then when she gets up the
conversation gets so heated between
ramona
luanne and ebony mostly luanne and ebony
because
ebony's just trying to make the point
like you know just because you want to
be sex positive like they just make you
trashy
and then luanne said this but kept
denying that she said it she's like it's
not about
like class it's about education and so
ebony took that as a slight well she's
like well i don't care what leah says
and i'm the most educated person at this
table
yeah and i guess luanne went to nursing
school so she's going to forgot
she's like don't come to my house and
tell me i'm not educated and they're all
just yelling at each other and it's so
chaotic
and then ramona and luanne are like calm
down ebony when it's like ebony wasn't
louder than anyone else and ramona's so
[ __ ] dramatic pushes her chair out a
couple feet and she's like
she's like that's fine i'm just gonna
move back because you're hurting my ears
i have an ear condition
and it's just like so stupid because
they're all being just as loud and
chaotic
literally ramona goes from telling ebony
to calm down to literally standing up
and banging on the table so
it was so clear that they were just like
they were microaggressions and ebony was
feeling it
so hard and she was like doing her best
to remain calm but like they were just
being so hypocritical like calm down
ebony and it's like
calm down like you're screaming like
yeah so where they left it was like
ebony stormed off and
is visibly upset and luanne is like
seeing red like luanne cannot
even like address ebony like it was it
got so heated and it was very difficult
to follow and there was so much going on
and literally like they were talking
about nothing like it wasn't even like a
real argument like
i couldn't honestly i'm retelling it to
you and i i'm not even sure i'm
retelling it correctly like like the
crux of those i don't know what the real
point they were
all trying to make was something about
education class and sex like
i honestly have no idea yeah and sonia
is just sitting there
mining her own goddamn business as is
the only person who was trying to like
you know
be like a medium was heather i mean she
was somewhat successful
in that but she was just trying to get
them all to like chill
and like see eye to eye but she failed
yeah it was like it was chaotic i think
that and ebony posted on instagram like
she's
like taking a break from social media
for the next two weeks because like this
episode was like kind of heavy for her
and i guess what happens next week like
gets even more into the classroom
there was a tubing okay and it was
actually like sometimes i feel like they
throw a tb
a tbc in there like so unnecessarily
yeah but i did feel like it was very
appropriate
oh nice okay i'm excited to watch and
what's on tonight beverly hills beverly
hills okay cool
and charles's sunset was on sunday and
honestly it really wasn't a good episode
like we all know mike's lying we're all
just like you know waiting for him to
admit it you know yeah it was
not great but i think there's like a new
new cast member
that added this girl london who seems
like really random
she's persian she's friends with mj
she's a lesbian
and three episodes in now and i'm like i
literally forgot she was in the house
like when i first met her she kind of
had like eclectic energy
i'm not feeling that at all then they
brought in this other girl last night
who or sunday night who has been on an
episode like years ago like her and gigi
were like going at it now like her and
gg your friends
it just seems like honestly there's a
lot going on in the group i don't really
feel like they need
anyone let alone two new people and then
sherman showed up like
it was just kind of chaotic like they're
going horseback riding it was just like
a lot
nice it wasn't my favorite episode okay
um
but speaking of my favorite things yeah
it's time for deer toasters which is our
advice segment
i'm just laughing to myself because this
episode is all you experiencing thanks
to you what are you doing with friends
i know i think we should call it claudia
explains it all the time
the one and two talk like i just spent
the whole weekend because it was raining
like on my phone so yeah i know
everything no claudia explains it all
she's like clarissa before her the more
you know the more you know that's why i
was just like smiling oh okay yeah i was
like did i see something funny
no you just i wouldn't put it past me
oh you never laugh like that things um
funny again
wouldn't put it past me um we're going
to do your toasters but we have a very
exciting announcement for deer toasters
because we have a
very special episode coming out next
week that's really centered on deer
toasters so if you've been thinking
about writing in
or you've been wanting to write in or
you have an update for us anything
email your toasters gmail.com of course
it's always anonymous we'll change
people's names you know your pri
your privacy is important to us but i
think you'll want to get in on this
episode
next week so dear toasters at gmail.com
is the email you can always write there
but for this specific episode we think
you guys are really going to like it so
email if you've been like holding out
like should i shouldn't i have this
quandary like is that like
the weirder the better yeah is it like
dramatic write in like write in
you would want to get your advice you
won't regret it for this one
um and so today's steer up dear toasters
we have two submissions and a new update
is brought to you by noom think about
everything you've ever learned about
getting healthy there's a lot of
contradictory information out there and
things like that old-fashioned food
pyramid are not
much help you know how to chew and use
chopsticks and fold pizza
but usually you don't know how to eat
noon says if you want to lose weight
it's not about one thing you ate today
but how you eat in general
numa is based in psychology they teach
you how to eat so you can accomplish
your personal health goals and stick
with them long term
because you don't need rules to lose
weight you need knowledge and with nume
you pick the health goals that are right
for you and they will personalize a
weight loss program
to help your aspirations become a
reality so whatever reason you want to
get in shape if you want to lose weight
if you just want to feel better you want
to finish some of your clothes whatever
milestone it is everyone has their own
reasons for wanting to
get in shape noon can help you with
all of it yeah i love noom we've been
using noon for years and especially in
these last few months i've used noon to
like stay on track and just like keep me
abreast
of my progress and i have just had like
so much personal um success with it and
i recommend it to everyone my friends my
family anyone
who wants to start living well and
really does not know where to start like
noom says it's all about knowledge and
education and like
noon provides all of that for you so if
you don't know where to start
new noom's cognitive behavioral approach
means you're not just losing weight
you're building the habits you need to
keep it off
they're very forgiving because you're
human so if you go off track you'll just
get back on track tomorrow
everyone is busy so they only ask for 10
minutes a day and over 80 percent of
numerous finish the program and over 60
have stuck with their goals for at least
one year there's a science to getting
healthier and it's called new
sign up for your trial today at noon n o
o
m dot com slash toast if you're ready to
learn how to live healthier sign up for
noom today
at noomnoom.com toast
love it all right first up dear claudia
and jackie the toast has literally saved
my
saved me through the queue so thank you
i'm currently having an issue with my
boyfriend of one year we are moving
states together this month so he can
start his
medical residency oh doctor and misses
hello hello
we have talked about engagements and
getting married he is the one i am now
in a current debacle because he's
getting a tattoo covered up
wait sorry he is getting a tattoo
covered up with what is planned to be
this
horrible realistic scary looking skull
and i mean
scary like satanic i've tried to talk to
him about why he's choosing this and if
he can please do something else because
it really upsets me
he says he just loves the design and
it's his body so he should be able to do
whatever he wants with it
i respect that but as a couple i feel
like you should take my opinion
seriously
it's so bad what do i do shut up and
look at my whole life or plead until i'm
blue in the face
for him to get something else thank you
this is a real quandary yeah because
like it
is his body but also like it's kind of
like happening like you gotta look at it
yeah and i don't know like i feel like
let's say you were getting botox okay
well not you because you do get botox
like
if you were you're married or engaged
cosmetic enhancement you would talk to
your partner about it obviously right
yes but at the end of the day
it's your decision it's your decision so
it's kind of bothering me that he's not
even like listening to you
he should at least like fake listen and
pretend to take it into consideration
just like for the sake of your feelings
but at the end of the day like it's his
body and maybe you'll end up liking it i
don't know like schools are kind of cool
i don't know i'm curious what is he
covering up what's the tattoo that's
there is it worse than this like maybe
we could leave it right that's what i
was thinking like is it an
ex-girlfriend's name like
what is it would you prefer that maybe
it was just like a drunken mistake
yeah this is tough i think that at the
end of the day
it's his choice and whatever it is like
it will grow on you like it'll just
become a part of him and you won't even
remember that you disliked it i just
think the fact that like you're waiting
for it to be drawn on is like giving you
anxiety
yeah also like how many other tattoos
does he have why now why this tattoo
yeah like is it just one big skull on
his belly or like is he tatted up
yeah i need photos it's a skull amongst
you know tons of other artistry
i need more contacts and also i i think
i have to say like i don't know
yeah me neither because i this is not if
we're comparing it to cosmetic
enhancements then i would say
it's hit like it's just it's his choice
but
no honestly it's the same thing as
getting like lip filler
you think yeah like the other person
wants to look at it lip filler is not
permanent
oh that's true okay let's say a boob job
a boob job yeah that's what i was
thinking
yeah if she wants it and he didn't like
it
it's too bad like she wants it yeah we
have to give the same
sort of respect and like agency yeah
to him okay if that's if those are
equitable then i think that they are
they're permanent
yeah body changing modification
modifications yeah
okay so it sucks but you'll just you'll
have to work on it and honestly like
think there's some it could be so many
worse things like
you could look it up like some of the
worst tattoos ever like yeah it's just
it's just not your style
yeah it'll grow on you if you love him
and he loves it but osmosis like you'll
love it
yeah if a equals b and b equals c then a
c and you'll you're gonna learn to love
the tattoo
but um can't wait till we use that
advice on ourselves yeah right
ben wants to do something crazy grows
out his beard he loves it all right hey
claudia and jackie thanks for being
absolutely hilarious and brightening my
mood every day
me and my friends are longtime toasters
and when i told them that when i told
them something that recently happened to
me they all agreed that i needed to get
your advice wow it sounds like you have
such a great group of friends maybe we
should all hang out
so last week i downloaded hinge for the
first time this was my first time
downloading any dating apps you can
imagine how nervous i was to go on my
first date last night
the date was going well but i kept
having to get up to pee when we were
finished with dinner my date said he
would wait with me outside the
restaurant until my uber arrived
i really had to pee again but i didn't
want to think i was a freak for peeing
so much so i decided to hold it in
of course my uber ended up taking 11
minutes to arrive and this was too long
for me to hold my pee
it was then that i decided my best and
only option was to pee my pants
in front of him standing on the sidewalk
also i should mention that i only had
two drinks so this was basically a sober
thought and decision
so as we were standing wait i just like
no i can't get on board with the logic
no you're less of a freak for peeing in
your pants than you are for going to use
the bathroom right
right like make it make sense so as we
were standing outside talking i began to
slowly pee myself by spurting out small
increments of urine i feel like
someone's pranking us
yeah continue luckily i was wearing
black jeans so we wouldn't be able to
see my pee pants but then the piece
started to leak out of my pants and onto
my suede sneakers
only a few drops got on my sneakers so
i'm not sure if you noticed by the time
my uber arrived my pants were completely
soaked and pee and my bladder was fully
empty
i blacked out during our conversation
since i was so focused on peeing my
pants discreetly i have no idea if he
thought
it went well or if he wants to go on
another date i was wondering if you guys
think i should reach out again or if i
need to throw in the towel and try again
with someone else
if you didn't notice it wouldn't be that
big of a deal right but what if he did
notice and still wants to go out
that's even weirder right what do you
think my next move should be sincerely
honey i peed my pants
i just feel like before we kind of get
into dealing with you know how
you shouldn't you with him i think
there's some work that needs to be done
on you like let's you just kind of like
breeze by the decision to like not walk
back into the restaurant and pee your
pants like that as if that was like kind
of normal
as if that's an option like that's
really not i thought you were gonna say
like okay you peed in the bushes like
okay i might do that i'm not gonna lie
like
i don't understand the thinking behind
the ping of the pants like that
that that to me is something that we
need to talk about before
you because honestly before you can kind
of give yourself to someone else like
you have to be
cool with yourself and like i'm just
like you were too embarrassed to go to
the bathroom again
like too self-conscious to go to the
restroom and you ruined a good pair of
jeans
and what about the uber driver's car
totally very daddy right justice for the
uber driver
and justice for like your switch
sneakers i'm i i don't want to be too
hard on you because i
you obviously like are probably feeling
guilt since you wrote in
no but see the thing is that i do feel
like we're being i feel like this is not
a true story honestly
we're being pranked like 100 i really
feel that way no because
the the whole reason she wrote in is not
like
you know how should i work on myself to
stop peeing my pants it was
texas guy again whereas honestly i have
a question for you did you have a good
time do you want to text him again
take away the fact that you peed your
pants like why treat it as a normal
situation like
you said that you did it in small
increments hopefully he didn't see so
let's operate that he didn't know like
how small he still has been if it was
coming out of your pants no he still
hasn't texted you this is any
like aside from peeing the pants this is
any other like first date he hasn't
texted me what should i do should i text
him i'll ask you did you
do you want to go out with him again if
so hit him up yeah
i just think there's work that needs to
be done but if he did um
if he didn't notice then i i wouldn't um
ever contact him
i wouldn't expect a response ever again
but you know what then you hear those
stories of like girls who go on first
date with a guy they do something so
crazy like [ __ ] their pants
throw up throw up on them in the uber
get too drunk
married yeah no that's true but like
honestly this is kind of different
like i don't i actually think this is
like something you can't come back from
i agree
and you know what i feel like if you
were comfortable enough with him on the
first date and there was that good
rapport like you would have used the
restroom
you know i'm just like i can't get over
the hurdle of like thinking it's a
better idea to pee in your pants and
just like quickly run back into the
restaurant
yeah yeah so good luck
all right our third and final dear
toasters is an update hey ladies i've
got an update for you all i wrote into
your toasters back in october about my
ex-boyfriend
dating my current boyfriend's sister do
you remember my
ex-boyfriend dating my current boyfriend
sister okay and they were talking about
like family meals she thought maybe it
was like out of spite you know okay
let's fast forward to now how do i
remember that and not you only six
months after announcing their
relationship to the family they got
engaged
and getting married in october i've been
processing this for a while now and i
still don't know how i feel
long story short it hasn't been pretty i
moved out of me and my boyfriend's home
of three years i just couldn't bear
living next door to my ex-boyfriend any
longer we live on a family ranch
operated by my boyfriend and his sister
wow sounds like a nice life um so i
guess they were like living near each
other yeah
i'm currently interviewing for jobs
nationwide and have tendently accepted a
position on the other side of the
country starting at the beginning of
july
there have been some very low lows in my
relationship but this has only
strengthened it
he's a p-john and he'll do everything he
can to support me but how much can i ask
of him
here's a list of my quick complaints no
one in the family has had enough respect
for me or my boyfriend to talk to us
about this relationship or give us a
heads up about the engagement because
his mom knew it was coming
that's really it i just want respect
from his sister my ex and his family
after his mom found out i moved out she
asked me to lunch where she sobbed with
guilt and admitted that
she and the sister should have handled
this better other than that i haven't
heard one word from his sister
with my cross-country move approaching
my heart is breaking with the thought of
being away from him
he brought he brought up moving with me
oh she's moving without him
oh he brought up moving with me but this
would mean leaving his family ranch
behind
and would be a massive betrayal to his
family is this something i should ask
him this man is my soul mate but i'm
ready for bigger and better things than
this
tiny town incest sincerely well she
wrote with an update
and another problem um sincerely toaster
has a big problem
being tunnel buddies with her
sister-in-law okay a few things like i
think at the end of the day you need to
decide if you love this man
more than you hate your ex yeah because
it seems like right now like you're
letting this
you're letting them win yeah and it's
kind of like sucky that
it's a family situation where like
everybody lives on the same ranch like
because
ordinarily you could just like see them
at holidays and whatever um but also
it's kind of sweet like you would live
the ranch life i don't know if that's
like what you're looking for but like
that sounds like a dream honestly
i and they're getting married and so at
this point it's like
it's so weird like it's still so weird
it's so weird
um and i i can understand why you're
like if only they had handled it better
but i still think like you would be just
as
hurt so i do feel like that's sort of
like a yes and now this is one of those
situations where it's like
okay like maybe they got together out of
spite whatever like
it was weird when it happened but now
they're getting married and like we just
like kind of have to get over it like it
is like a true love situation apparently
like they're getting married yeah
so as much as it sucks i do feel like
you're kind of like
throwing your life into chaos just to
get away from this man it makes me
like you say this that the man you're
with is your soul mate but like
if that were the case like you might be
more at peace with your boyfriend kind
of moving in on your life and it is
really weird like your ex
i'm not trying to but are you really
just gonna like
why are you gonna punish yourself right
and like now live away from your
boyfriend
and i don't know it just feels like you
had a really nice thing and
and you can work it out but you're
instead like running away from it and
also like
causing more problems so yeah you're
gonna be living longer and like you're
gonna be
even unhappier i feel like i i think
that you
if this man is your soul mate that you
should stay
you shouldn't they shouldn't like get
love and then you are alone across the
country and like
both you and your ex or your current
boyfriend are miserable and if the
family ranch is his future
then that is where you need to be if you
want to be with him
if he like is offering to leave the
ranch and you think that like
that is a good idea i don't think you
should take him away from the ranch
yes it sounds like there's a position
that needs to be filled at as female
head of the ranch
and i think that i'm the woman for the
job i think you are too
i don't know i just like i don't want
them to win
no yeah and it seems like you're not
only letting them win but like you're
kind of like
like ruining your own life like running
away
and cutting off your nose just by your
face exactly
yeah and i don't know if i agree with
that i don't know it's your life and you
have to do what you like to survive
is making me sad whereas like i want you
to put your bones on
get down to the ranch milk some cows rub
some dirt in it
rub some [ __ ] dirt in it and be
the matriarch of that ranch yeah no it
seems like that was a role you were born
to play in like one little hiccup and
you're running away
i think that you can face this head-on
you sound brave and strong and it's
weird and i'm not
down it's gonna be easy but i think it
will be worth it
nothing in life is easy nothing worth
having is easy yeah i gotta fight for
what you want you gotta fight
i don't think you should run away this
really does sound like a hallmark movie
like
storyline yeah rub some dirt in it
five words for you rub some dirt in it
and
that's our show and that was your
toasters again dear toasters at
gmail.com we have a big special episode
coming up for dear toasters would love
your guys's experiences anonymously of
course
deartoasters gmail.com thank you theo
for being here jackie thank you for
listening to my monologue thank you for
coming to my ted talk
thank you for thank you for educating me
on everything that
happened this weekend i can't i can't
you know lie and say tomorrow might be
different
hopefully it won't tomorrow i hope to be
abreast yeah we'll be watching real
housewives of beverly hills
yes and i think that's all that's on
tonight yeah yeah but i'll be reading
all day if you're looking for me
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast the millennial morning
show where we deliver the past five
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up we're also
available as a podcast anywhere podcasts
can be found so it's spotify itunes
stitcher public radio i already know
catbox all the places
swear to me listen to the podcast fine
nice morning until super 5 star review
but i beautiful stunning and smart we
are
hope you guys have an amazing hump day
don't forget to hump someone you love
got to go home theo have a great day
goodbye